all aboard the polar espresso
let's head back to red rock casino's
mary crimson rocky is showing us where
we can get into the holiday spirits this
season
so one of the things i love most about
mary crimson the holiday pop-up bar are
the interactive cocktails i know so much
goes into designing these with each
concept every season so what does it
take to design them for this year well
it's definitely a pop-up bar aspect so
every year we do a different theme this
one was a little more classy as far as
like the white and gold so we definitely
went with that but we still wanted to
give that light element okay so here we
go with this cocktail here and you're
pouring it into like a
bowl burger what is that absolutely it's
like a snow globe here if you want to
top that off with red bull for me this
one is actually the all my friends are
snowflakes with the coconut berry bread
bowl coconut red bull i've never even
heard of that yeah
absolutely and you said this is called
all my friends are snowflakes all my
friends are snowflaking you can see it
has that glow here
i'm gonna add some christmas tree
aspects to this cocktail oh the rosemary
the rosemary
how does it light up it's actually some
led lights in there and we actually
change it to the blue and then to give
it true to its name we put in some sugar
snowflakes here so beautiful this is not
your average cocktail people look how
beautiful this is
the little gifts that come to your table
yes holidays here we have the
slay all day package here which is our
shop package we have the milk and
cookies for santa with the boozy
chocolate milk so good and this one is
the deer santa next year i promise which
actually comes to you tableside in the
mailbox and taylor did i hear there's a
secret menu yes so if you're feeling
frosty you can come up to your bartender
and ask them do you want to build a
snowman and get a special surprise ooh i
love those speakeasy vibes absolutely
and this is very good by the way i'm so
glad you're enjoying that cocktail oh my
gosh okay so what's the vibe here you
work the bar you you see everything what
what kind of energy are people getting
when they walk in it's definitely high
energy it's christmas time so
everybody's in the good spirit everyone
has positive energy so we have the dj
which great music so it's always a good
vibe in here and speaking of good vibes
if you're over at enchanted you guys
provide a shuttle absolutely you can
have two holiday experiences in one
night yes it's actually called the mary
crimson express so if you're
experiencing enchanted you can just go
ahead and get expressed right over to
mary crimson and have a
time obviously this is 21 and up bar
so
great
okay so it's not you can't have your
family over at enchanted and then bring
the kids over right this is definitely
the date night situation exactly it's so
much fun look at these beautiful couches
so romantic so high energy and fun for
the holidays you guys can make a
reservation on their website but you
don't need one you download that too
that's another gift you guys give us
absolutely you can just come out to the
bar and hang out with me perfect all
right jayla thank you cheers cheers and
i'll send it back to you
we gotta go we have to check that out it
looks awesome looks like so much fun for
the holidays are